sur la fin on s'appelle hélas tranquille
us depuis sept ans pierre paquin donne
des ateliers scientifiques à la demande
des écoles 5 septembre
il sort avec des élèves de 5e année de
l'école saint marc pour faire une chasse
aux blanchons que j'avais vu la renier
la mode les vrais la vigne et esbly prix
qui est un super pierre m'avait dit
d'eux qu'ils voudraient bien les amis
parce qu'il ya l'art comme elle à la
plus intéressante avec les élèves
ça c'est peut-être une des meilleures
prises qu'on a fait parce que c'est un
espèce que jamais été trouvées au québec
doublement intéressant s'alarmant d'une
part qu'on connaît pas tous encore des
choses à découvrir même appelé rappelle
marianne ses soeurs qui est des taxis
les noms les deux sont revenus dans la
ruelle à côté de l'école avec le battoir
le parapluie japonais il aspirateur
c'est quelque chose qui peut être utile
pour moi fait j'ai besoin de comparer
avec d'autres spécimens scales un drop
peut-être ne fera pas alors ce que j'ai
fait avec elle j'en ai donné une
beaucoup plus grosse tête très content
d'avoir une bonne taille en échange de
celle qu'elle avait qu'on avait trouvé
cela la ruelle et le nom d'alexandra
figurent dans le rapport d'observations
publié par l'areq nos loeb pierre paquin
bien connu à l'insectarium de montréal
c'est un des pionniers au québec ce
jusqu à date des experts notent une
tendance à la hausse du nombre d'espèces
qui réussissent à s'établir au québec
c'était une espèce qui étaient aux
frontières du québec pierre paquin et
prudent est ce que c'est parce qu'elle
est il fait plus chaud est ce que c'est
parce que
elle est vraiment arrivé récemment est
ce que c'est parce que quelqu'un a
déménagé puis mes parents du tableau et
c'est aussi peut aimer les sciences
faire classe de découverte
ce jour là elle a trouvé des insectes
mais pas de traquer l'astre en qui lui
ce l'araignée d'alexandra reste unique
pour l'instant ici à nourrice despatie
radio canada montréal